hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to kevin
samuels it's a video called
i'm just fine with my cats and tats i'm
a big cat band
so i'm just trying to see what this is
about before i start i'm going to keep
this short
do not forget to like comment and
subscribe my goal is to hit 15 000
subscribers this week so if you want to
hit if you like this content if you
don't like my content
don't subscribe but if you like this
content do not forget to hit that
subscribe button
alright short and quick right you think
it took too long
just let me know let me know okay
i'm not even gonna lie kevin samuel's
content it's kind of like crack like
it's very addicting
i've never had crack but i would imagine
ask your questions
well do you have any kids yeah
go ahead okay so i work in tech i
make like over six figures and
i guess a question for you that i have
is
let's say if you're talking about like
high value man i'm not sure what your
definition is it seems like it seems to
revolve around like if i'm asking for
somebody to be
my equal which is make the same amount
as me or be in a similar industry
um and like have their or at least be
ambitious in some way they don't unless
they don't have to make 100 figures but
like
a
[Music]
he has to make a certain amount of ten
thousand dollars a month
for three to five years other high value
man has to recognize him as a peer
he has to have a network of high value
men and other people
what he does is linkedin level meaning
visibility can't just have a vague title
i wonder if my dad would be considered
high value
because he may he has the money but he
doesn't really like
people like he has people i swear my
whole life
my dad always had like people that like
wanted to be his friend but my dad just
really doesn't like people
but he like ran a successful company
and but he doesn't have social media
like he hates
like i'm an entrepreneur i mean
something like i'm the head of
vp immersion acquisition at goldman
sachs and then
he's just okay so that's in general what
a high value man means
in basic terms so
and look i wanted before i know i know
where this is going but i wanted to add
two cents i've like thought about kevin
samuels content a lot
and his content is very similar to like
uh what i would call like a corporate
millionaire and there's two different
types of like
millionaires there's like the
millionaires that or like people that
makes
figures whatever that are like in
corporate america and like climb the
ladder
maybe like climb the ladder and then
start their own company and then there's
people that have like
built something of their own and they're
like completely different
kinds of millionaires like the values
and just like
the way they move are completely
different like
my dad like he would never take like a
fashion course
he does not care like he does his thing
builds his business
but like fashion he does not care and
then there's like
people that are in like corporate
america where that's like
image look very important to them i
don't know just
my two cents you're in tech and do
you're doing what many women do you're
putting your education and your income
into your sexual marketplace value
and that's not how it works with man
and i like agree with him
for maybe like the guys that just want a
trophy wife but
i've been having conversations with like
guy friends asking
like what stuff is important to them and
i've had a lot of like
my guy friends say that they've like
dumped women
because they didn't find them to be
smart and not educated two different
things but smart
let me know in the comments saying
somebody who's sorry agree or disagree
equal
uh your equal is what's in the mirror
okay
when it comes to men that's the that's
the harsh truth that's where we start
so i guess like the asymmetry is that
women women look for like value in terms
of what they provide
men look for value in terms of what
would look like is that what you're
saying
women look for resources men look for
beauty
okay okay so what's good enough for you
um what's going on for me is somebody
who is ambitious
regardless of their income um again i've
done this before earlier you could be an
ambitious yugioh player
you could be an ambitious esports gamer
do you
let's be honest you want somebody who
has resources
you don't want somebody making thirty
thousand dollars a year
uh i'm fine with somebody making forty
thousand dollars a year
okay cool yeah let's go let's let us do
this then
let us do how much are you earning
annually uh 120.
and what state do you live in i live in
i live in canada over toronto
canada and you're 26. i'll put you
ladies back and i'm gonna bring you back
up um
do you want children brandi uh yeah
eventually
yeah uh yeah eventually
um yeah not right now yeah and you'll be
and you'll be fine
paying the lion's share the bills
uh yeah maternity leave in canada is
cool so no no no no no no if you had a
guy making 40 000
a year and you're making how much 120
so that's 160 total so that means
um 160
and he's making 40 divided by 160.
so yeah that means every time you win a
third of what i'm saying yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah actually 25 percent
so 40 over 120 is a third i thought you
said making 160 or 30. okay
so the bottom so bottom line is this if
you had a 3 000
mortgage or a 3 000 or 3 000 mortgage
you're paying two thousand he's paying a
thousand
you got a car note that's 500 bucks
you're paying
two thirds of that he's paying the third
everything that happens
you she does not look happy look at her
face order cheeseburger mcdonald's you
paying two thirds he's paying a third
and you're doing this for a lifetime
with no problems
you're gonna still be cooper fit you
could still be cooperative submissive
respectful
yeah i mean that's what i'm currently
living i'm already paying for 100 of my
bills
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
and i skipping one to the other we're
gonna process what i said
yeah you're gonna still be yes sir no
sir
i'm not no i mean that cooperative
submissive
you're not gonna uh pull financial rank
on him
well i could be cooperative submissive
without being yesterday or snowster
ah i see there's there's see but i'm not
going for somebody who's so much no
don't overtalk me
they're already showing you're already
showing problems right now
right now you're already showing them
so i just have a question for the kevin
samuels fans that are like watching this
do you think that average guys really
care if a woman's submissive like a guy
that's making 40k
because i've seen a lot of marriages
where like the woman definitely isn't
submissive but they seem like happy
and stuff and like they're married for a
long time and the woman just like makes
more than the guy
glad you got a cat you may want to hold
that [ __ ] for a long time
i'm currently in everyone you currently
what i'm not single
i'm not single you're not married
damn no i'm not good i mean you're the
cat we can count
i'm telling what i'm saying a
conversation i'm having with you and
you've
overtalked me so many times i'm sitting
there trying to slow you down
at the end of the day if you had it
figured out you wouldn't be here
so why are you here if you already know
and you're already in a relationship why
are you here why don't you move on
let me help let me go ahead and move on
since you already know well because i
go ahead you're asking an open question
i just wanted to answer it yeah
but you already know but it's good
enough for a modern woman i wanted to
give my two cents
you're two cents to 26. i wanted to see
what your perspective was
wow you already gotta see what you're
doing what's your main thing how long
you been with your boyfriend
uh a year okay are y'all getting married
not anytime soon though how long do you
guys think that you should date someone
before you get
married because personally like i'd be
okay with dating someone for two years
before we got married
but he seems to make it like very quick
like six months to marry someone that's
that's pretty fast
right uh-huh does he want to get married
but i will make a caveat if you're older
like as an older girl i understand that
that's like
you can make it a smaller time frame but
she's not like that old she's like 26.
eventually yeah does he want to get
married to you
uh i mean i no i don't know
i think it's early i don't know if i'm
wondering i'm 29 a year is not really
early
it's not really early because the
follow-up question i was going to ask
you
since you already got a man my
perspective really shouldn't matter it
should be your man's perspective that
matters
yeah oh she doesn't want to marry him
i can tell
what does he think
where is he at where is he at
he's he's at home okay
so you're here we're talking about
relationship and that's about what's
good enough for modern women
and you're involved in a relationship
with a year with a guy and
you don't know whether or not you and
you guys aren't trending towards
marriage but you want to be married one
day
you do or you don't i do by what age
would you like to be married
in my 30s in your 30s could be 30 in one
day or 39
and i got 32. 30 how 32
yeah 32. so let's say uh six years from
now
okay and how many would you like to have
children one or two yeah
which one one or two it
it depends on how like the first one
goes
um i say that too it's hard to say how
many kids you want
if you don't know like if you've never
been a parent
because this is a poor example
but i have a dog right and i used to say
i wanted five dogs then i took care of
one
i'm good on that i'm good but one for
sure and then
if like the first one goes well then the
second one yeah i say the same thing
okay and
one child is i grew up as an only child
it sucks
don't do that to a kid but anywho um
once you're married do you want to have
to put your kid in daycare or
or you want to are you going you want to
work
the entire time uh yeah well yeah i'm
gonna work so we're gonna have to do
daycare
yeah um hopefully by the time i'm 32 i'm
making significantly more than what i
want to make
but significantly more okay but
again you're prepared to be the
breadwinner
yeah okay and what what what
relates what tends to happen to
relationships so women tend to be the
breadwinner
what does the dynamic tend to be like
oh that's dependent on the personality
of the woman
oh no it really doesn't
okay but i don't know what he suggests
that she do
like clearly i mean she's not bad
looking but she's not like super hot
and the guys that are on her like salary
level
aren't like gonna be interested in her
based on what kevin samuel says
so what is she supposed to do dumb
herself down like
not everyone's given like the hand for a
traditional marriage
um i'm not sure i'm not sure how you
want me to answer i think it depends
like if the if the woman is making 55
and the men is making 45 percent i could
see a very like
uh dynamic and like equal partnership
relationship going on
even though she's like the primary
writer in terms of percentage
so it's just equal it's it's it's just
an equal power distribution
we're just living in a utopian
environment you're pulling
you're pulling in two-thirds of the
financial load but it's 50 50.
actually you're still cooperative and
submissive just not saying yes sir
no sir right yeah i mean like i have an
opinion but i
want to i want that person to be
assertive as well i want them to tell me
what they think and i want us to get to
a common ground but we both agree
question does he think that it should
just be like whatever the man say
goes and like there's no compromise or
input from the woman
or is he just saying like the man has
the final
set like i'm just curious what exactly
he means
[Music]
yeah it's a very masculine thing to want
again what what is she supposed to do
people like that
yeah some guys like that they're called
[ __ ]
[ __ ] and beta males would be the kind
of men they would put up with the
domineering masculine woman
i don't know if he means like dominant
because like the way she's like
acting and like talking right now or if
he just means money
because again what are high performing
women supposed to do
like perform less like
especially if she's not like super hot
what does he want her to do the only
[ __ ] will go for a woman in equal
partnership
no no no no masculine
i'd say you're not equals that's the
thing men and women are not equals
equality yeah equity i don't mean like
exactly the same i do i say well no what
i say it is masculine
okay and you can be
you can be two sides of a coin but a
feminine versus masculine
you're in your masculine energy you want
to get on the same page and everything
else
normally i would tell you to put your
dick up but your cat already
ran away so your [ __ ] left oh my gosh
here actually
okay we'll put your [ __ ] up
like what is she saying she's not really
giving her an answer what is she
supposed to do
dumb herself that like
like if the guy's making the kind of
money she makes don't want her is she
just supposed to be alone forever
make less money not sure like so
okay so you're saying that i have a
masculine energy is what you're saying
so i have to tone down my ambassador i'm
not telling you you have to do anything
i'm just telling you have hella
masculine energy
okay i agree with that
so what do you think is masculine energy
and
masculine energy draws feminine men
but my current partner isn't feminine at
all though alrighty then
well you found the you found the key to
the nether zone
you found the masculine man i feel like
if
that her partner had everything she
wanted she wouldn't have called into the
show
they accepts a masculine woman does he
how to earn you
no alrighty then
um exhibit a
he didn't really give her a solution to
be honest
um so this is an interesting
conversation like
i totally understand like what he's
saying but like from that girl's shoes
i've said this a couple times but like
what would your solution be
if you're at that level of
attractiveness right where she's at
and the guy's making the kind of money
that you make aren't interested in you
are you just supposed to die alone
are you supposed to like put less into
your career
i don't know like honestly like i feel
like if a feminine guy
is like or a guy making less than hers
better than like
just being by yourself and plus
i don't know i've seen relationships
work where
the girl makes more than the guy like i
don't think it's like dead
set in stone and that's the thing that
kind of bothers me is in the
in like these shows is it's not like
real life
you know like he speaks in absolutes
like in society
in general but like as an individual you
can find something that like works for
you
but maybe i'm wrong let me know in the
comments either way don't forget to like
comment
and subscribe get me to 15 000.
please okay bye